Postmates won't stop ringing my doorbell
when I order
[Applause]
it all that happens is I [__] put up
a sign that says don't ring the doorbell
please baby you
sleeping and they [__] show up and I
there's no way they don't see the sign
and they [__] ring a doorbell anyway
oh wait no so here's what actually
happened I [__] put in the Postmates
thing please don't ring the doorbell a
baby is sleeping they don't read the
notes on Postmates apparently and I can
say that now because they're not
sponsors of this show Uber Eats drivers
read the notes I write in Uber Eats hey
guys please don't R the doorbell have a
toddler and every time I don't even know
who delivers the food it's like a
goddamn ninja works for Uber
Eats sometimes I'm just like I hear I'm
like oh the food's here
here oh what the [__] the food's here
dude I think I just saw a flash of a
sword getting in a [__]
Prius um I saw a [__] Uber drive an
Uber Eats guy with a dope car today it
was weird as [__] this pandemic is
getting
everybody um
anyway anyway uh so I get so sick of
this and when when your boy gets pissed
he works he works on it and he's been
working on it and he's been in therapy
for it over the last bunch of months and
he's trying to not get pissed cuz he
learned that anger is a huge reason for
why he is the way that he is and he
wants to just be chilling he wants to be
sweet and Kristen says be nice and I say
you know what you're right but when I
say you know what you're right I feel
heat bubbling in my chest so I got to
get rid of
that so I talked to my therapist about
it and I try to be good about it but
this Postmates thing it happens every
time Postmates shows up ding dong 11 11
I tell Dude ding dong 11:00
p.m. good thing my baby sleeps Like a
Rock
um so yeah so I say you know what I'm
leaving a [__]
note I'll show it on the podcast but I
wrote a note on half of a paper towel
with a sharpie and the note was crinkled
up and I wrote leave food with an arrow
under it and then next to that I wrote
no
ring like a [__] I I mean it's on a
paper towel with a Shar with a half with
the Sharpie that's running out of ink
and it's spelled like a [__] Japanese
guy trying to learn
englishing leave food
noring so I [__] put it there and
Kristen opens the door for something
else during the day and she comes back
and when she comes back she looks at me
like it's raining Tomato Soup cans
outside and I say what's going on and
she goes are you [__] kidding me and
I'm
like this about the cheating and she's
like no this is about the [__] this
and she shows me the thing and it looks
like a [__] Ransom
note and she says this can't be on our
front door and I say not it's [__] to
the point it's succinct and she says
because it looks like a [__] Ransom
note and I say well what what the [__]
who cares I just say I care which is
something that I just won't ever
understand who cares it's just a sign
dude she ordered one on Amazon that says
like she was like so she was like not
mad but she was like you can't talk you
can't have
this you have to talk nice to people I'm
like even it's a sign just like even on
a sign you can't just say leave food no
ring they're going to be like oh the
biggest jackass of all time lives at the
[__] it looks like it's on toilet
paper to be
honest it's just no respect and I'm like
they're not showing me [__]
respect dude I come from a family do you
understand I come from a family my dad's
great
uncle used to go to this drugstore and
get his medication and every time the
guy went into the back room to get the
medication my uncle stole something a
little piece of thing whatever it was 99
Cents was probably 4 cents back then
because was [__] the year 1290 or
however old it was when my dad had a
[__] great grandpa or a great
uncle and one day my grandpa went in his
brother that guy's brother and he said
listen the drugstore guy said
listen um my dad told me the story when
I was a kid he said listen to this to to
to my to my grandpa my dad's dad um your
brother you know he's I know he's
getting getting older and um it doesn't
really it doesn't really bother me and I
I don't want to bring it up to him
because he's never really stealing
anything big but I know every time I go
back to get his pills he he he takes
something from the store and I don't
want to make a big deal out of it but
could you maybe just talk to him and and
get him to stop doing it this was back
in the [__] 40s or whatever this is
when people used to just be like hey
let's work it on on our own you know hey
look I know you're still from me but you
talk to him and you talk to the other
guy he a real Italian thing how about
you talk to him and he talk you have a
talk you have a sit down you still sit
down you get Jimmy to talk to him and
then Paulie will come in and you talk
you have a good time Carmine's there
he'll give you his Blessing and nobody
be stealing from anybody I could give
him his pills you understand I'm G to
have to [__] throw him
out so
he my my grandpa grandpa bam used to
call him cuz he used to be skinny uh
like a
bamboo stick which he wasn't when by the
time I was alive but um goes and he
talks to his brother my dad's great
uncle and he says now remember my dad
told me this when I was a kid and he
says hey um I got to talk to you and my
dad my grandpa's brother I forget his
name but he says uh yeah and he said bam
says you know I I was at the drugstore
and the guy the guy knows you're
stealing from him and uh he just doesn't
he doesn't want you to do it anymore and
uh that's all
so if you could just do it you know for
me and my dad's great uncle or my dad's
great uncle says yeah yeah I know he
knows and my grandpa says huh and he
says I know he knows and he says well if
you know he knows why do you do it and
he said that's why I do it his prices
are ridiculous he's robbing me so when
whenever he goes back to get my pills
that I have to pay high price for I take
a little something so it's
even that was the Inception
of that was the Inception dude that was
the [__] four of them just sitting in
a van going backwards into the
[__] that lake bed in the movie with
[__] Leonardo
my grandpa was Lardo DiCaprio and my
[__] great uncle was Tom Hardy and
then my dad was the Asian guy and then
whoever else was the [__] in it we
always forget and they were just ah it
was the Inception
dude and he's
like my dad told me that when I was
[__] like
10 so my point
is Postmates she's going to ring the
doorbell
he's going to get he's not going to
listen to the note on the
app he's going to get a half ass note on
some [__] [__] paper with a half used
Sharpie written like a [__]
Japanese this what she gonna
get I'm not [__] what am I gonna do
have a streamer and a parade and a
[__] no you [__] with me you get a
dirty
sign so I tell this to Chris Kristen and
she says oh you're a crazy
person but I'm not dude Tit for
Tat anyway we now have a really nice
flowery frilly [__] sign that we got
from Amazon Prime and it looks stupid in
front of the doorway and it says please
on it and then don't ring the doorbell
we have a sleeping baby so I'm a [__]
[Laughter]
and that's the [__] story
[Music]
dude she Taking Liberties it's my song
now dude